i told you before but i have to tell you
again i have to say congratulations
because you just have so much to
celebrate
right now i do want to talk a little bit
about the pregnancy if you don't mind
how are you feeling i feel fine um
yeah i'm not pregnant anymore the baby
came out so
oh you had the baby yeah oh my gosh
when you announced like last month that
you were pregnant
yeah i did that funny thing where uh i
basically was like four days away from
my due date and was like oh by the way
pregnant is it a boy is it a girl do you
have anything
a daughter named ida ida is that
does that name hold the special
significance or anything for you guys or
did you just love the name we just love
the name
yeah yeah and her middle name is lupin
which is um one of our favorite flowers
how are you doing are you sleeping is
this the most exciting time
for you right now yes yes and yes um
she's a good sleeper which is really
nice
and um yeah i can say without a doubt
that it is
for sure the most meaningful thing that
has ever happened to me and
i feel really lucky and yeah what was it
like
to give birth amid a pandemic
i've talked to some people who like to
wear masks
yeah i wore a mask everything was very
sick i mean very safe it was a really
really positive experience for me and
ben my partner and strangely like
um rather romantic
um just to see how how sweet and
supportive and connected
we were you know he was so sweet and
supportive towards me and
it was a wonderful experience yeah i
mean as far as a birth can go
you feel like it brought you guys closer
together in a way
oh i mean we're already very very very
close but i guess you can always get
closer and closer when
your love is healthy and good so that's
um that's something that i
that i'm grateful for every day that and
our sweet gal
i love hearing happy stories especially
during this climate so
thank you about that happy tish there
it's it's a genuinely good thing and
she's a sweet happy baby
and um being a mother is such a joy
yeah it's so cliche but i love it what
is it like to see him
as a dad oh ben is the most
beautiful at parenting he is such a good
father
and every day we take like a long walk
with ida and he he
wears her and like in the baby bjorn
thing
and like if she's if she's like making
any noise before she goes in there like
the second she goes against
his his body she's like
loves it a way of falling in love with
someone
i'm kind of in the same boat as you is
that i am also engaged in trying to plan
a wedding during all of this
are you guys wedding planning right now
or what does that look like
our wedding had been planned before the
pandemic and then we had to
move it so everything's all in place and
there's so much to
work with still even though of course
we've you know lost
the ability to kind of like congregate
in any way i think i spend the time
waiting to get married
uh thinking about what i'll say in my
vows and
being really excited that this is the
person that i get to marry
so it's it's a great way to focus up and
spend my time that way but yeah we like
you know
we pick the stuff welcome to the team
you're going to scream
i watched the first four episodes of
this series and i gotta tell you the
series felt
funny lighthearted warm
you're no stranger of course to animated
shows
what to you i guess felt different or
exciting about this the comedy
of the great north is is so unique the
voice is just so very special and i
think
as a comedian you're you're always
looking for something that's surprising
and that
isn't reiterative that that really sort
of takes a new space and
um and so i think our show really does
that and and as you said it's also it's
really warm
um for a show that takes place in alaska
um
yeah and i know i am looking for that in
the entertainment that i watch
these days is like i just want something
that is going to make me feel
good in a way that feels real um and it
isn't like a distraction but that
actually is like an
alternative to things that feel harder
and something that
that really feels real to me